[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein wir müssen in den
reichen ländern einsehen dass wir dem
anfang der pandemie näher sind als ihrem
ende sagt der britische solchen experte
jeremy vor das ist nicht das zitat mit
dem ich ihnen gerne komme an einem
sonntagabend es ist auf den ersten blick
ein weiteres stück depression im ohnehin
grauen winter
2021 aber es weist eben auch nach vorn
wir bekommen unser altes leben nicht mit
klein klein zurück allein mit
notfallmaßnahmen werden wir diese
pandemie dauerhaft nicht loswerden wir
brauchen eine weltumspannende strategie
und die es erstens nicht in sicht und
wird zweitens geld kosten auch darüber
spreche ich gleich mit deutschlands
designierte finanzminister der sich
heute die rückendeckung seiner partei
holen wollte für die künftige koalition
er hat sie bekommen die britta buchholz
und frank buchwald berichten
kleiner schritt auf der bühne großer
sprung für die fdp als christian lindner
vor acht jahren an die spitze der partei
rückt war sie gerade an der
fünf-prozent-hürde gescheitert vor vier
jahren führte die fdp zurück in den
bundestag nun geht er jeden schritt in
der 2017 noch scheute linter dirigieren
heute können wir sagen
es ist besser diese koalition zu vage
als auf gestaltungschancen zu verzichten
eine koalition mit spd und grünen
neuland für die liberalen im kabinett
neue gesichter bettina stark watzinger
etwa die volkswirtin aus frankfurt
übernimmt das bildungsministerium
hochschulpolitische erfahrung bringt sie
aus essen mit außerhalb der fdp aber ist
sie bisher kaum bekannt bildung für sie
vor allem aufstiegsversprechen
mit dem koalitionsvertrag schaffen wir
den einstieg in eine reform unserer
sozialsysteme weg vom reparaturbetrieb
hin zum chancengeber in unserer
gesellschaft bildung bei jung und
erstwählern liegt die fdp weit vorn bei
schülern und studenten rückenwind für
die jungen liberalen die in letzter zeit
wieder etwas aufmüpfiger sind es ist für
uns kenne keine belohnung für geleistete
arbeit und auch gerade keinen anlass
sich irgendwie hinzusetzen und zu sagen
super erste beste wählergruppe bei den
jung- und erstwählern dann setzen uns
jetzt auf unser büchern sondern im
gegenteil das ist ein auftrag dafür
sorge zu tragen dass die interessen
dieser jungen menschen die uns gewählt
haben um diesem land etwas zu verändern
dass die berücksichtigt werden in der
nächsten regierung da dürfte auch volker
wissing genau zuhören der jurist aus der
pfalz gilt als architekt der ampel
koalition er hatte ein solches bündnis
bereits in rheinland-pfalz geschmiedet
das er verkehrsminister werden soll hat
viele überrascht
deswegen will sich vor allem um schnelle
digitale zu kümmern von reisen zu
weihnachten bretter abwägen corona
impfpflicht für ihn eine gewissensfrage
dass sich die freien demokraten diese
entscheidung nicht leicht machen wird
von manchen kritisiert es ist aber keine
schwäche sondern unsere stärke dass wir
sensibler sind als andere wenn
freiheitsrechte scharf gegeneinander
abgewogen werden müssen marco buschmann
wald wohl justizminister hat in der
korona politik scharfe kritik einstecken
müssen von vielen seiten er gehört zu
den engsten vertrauten christian
lindners und gilt als cleverer stratege
freiheit und verantwortung für ihn eine
frage der verhältnismäßigkeit
verhältnismäßigkeit bedeutet nicht
dogmatisch an einmal gefundenen
ergebnissen festzuhalten
verhältnismäßigkeit bedeutet auf die
konkreten verhältnisse zu schauen
immerhin das finanzministerium haben die
liberalen erobert steuern werden nicht
erhöht auch die schuldenbremse bleibt am
ende stimmen die delegierten dem
koalitionsvertrag mit großer mehrheit zu
prüfungen für das liberale gewissen aber
werden schon noch kommen nicht nur beim
thema corona
christian lindner hat der fdp-chef ist
auf dem weg deutschlands neuer
finanzminister zu werden genannte
lindner guten abend herr sievers merken
sie jetzt gerade beim kampf gegen korona
den unterschied zwischen fordern in der
opposition und machen in der regierung
und das obwohl sie noch gar nicht
wirklich an der macht sind
ja richtig ist dass wir in einer sehr
herausfordernden zeit leben wir haben
die korona pandemie die keine
zögerlichkeit duldet und zugleich steht
eine noch nur geschäftsführende
bundesregierung einer neuen parlaments
mehrheit gegenüber das hat in den
vergangenen wochen die formulierung
einer konsequenten krisenstrategie
erschwert und deshalb ist es gut dass
dieser zustand ändert jetzt ist die fdp
bei der ganzen geschichte ein
ordentliches stück weg gegangen manche
sagen sie war er ist einfach auch die
die folgen der pandemie sind bei ihr
jetzt auch angekommen andere sagen das
war ein ganz schöner kurswechsel was
sagen sie denn herr lindner jetzt ihren
wählern die die fdp vielleicht auch
deshalb gewählt haben weil sie ihnen
vertrauten es werde keine impfpflicht
kommen und kein bundesweiter lockdown
auch kein faktischer für ungeimpfte
also zum einen haben wir das was wir
erreichen wollen in die gesamtstaatliche
krisenstrategie eingebracht es wird
jetzt im parlament über
grundrechtseingriffe entschieden im
bundestag und in den länderparlamenten
dafür wurde das infektionsschutzgesetz
geändert
ausgangssperren wird es nicht mehr geben
und wir hoffen dass es gelingt in diesem
winter auf flächendeckende lockdown zu
verzichten das angesichts von imf
durchbrüchen und der infektionszahlen
kontakt beschränkungen nötig sind ich
glaube das ist einsehbar und innerlich
straße immer sie sprachen über die
impfpflicht die fdp ist in dieser frage
der meinung dass das parlament
entscheiden muss nicht entlang von
fraktionslinie das muss eine
gewissensentscheidung sein in der fdp
gibt es stimmen die sind gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht bei uns gibt es
stimmen die sind für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht für beides gibt es argumente
wir sehen nach den zahlen der ard dass
77 prozent der wählerinnen und wähler
der fdp für eine impfpflicht bei
erwachsenen sind und das muss dann
zumindest der auftrag an die fdp seien
eine abstimmung offen zu lassen und den
abgeordneten die gewissensentscheidung
zu ermöglichen bei ihnen hört mal ein
bisschen raus herr lindner auch heute
wieder auf dem parteitag dass sie so
langsam richtung impfpflicht tendieren
ganz persönlich wie lang soll die denn
dann gelten also
für immer oder alle sechs monate immer
wieder neu gibt es dann auch eine
auffrischimpfung haben sie sich darüber
schon konkrete gedanken gemacht dem
deutschen bundestag werden sogenannte
gruppenanträge vorgelegt werden das
heißt abgeordnete unterschiedlicher
fraktionen unterbreiten einen
gesetzgebungsvorschlag die gibt es
gegenwärtig noch nicht und deshalb ist
das massiv fragen gegenwärtig noch nicht
zu beantworten ich glaube dass wir gut
daran tun die sehr sensible frage auch
sehr sorgfältig zu beraten
es gab ja eine zusage der politik an die
menschen von frau merkel über herrn
scholz herrenberg bis zu mir dass es
keine allgemeine impfpflicht gäbe es
jetzt sehr sorgfältig beraten werden die
länder als finanzminister als künftiger
finanzminister muss man weit nach vorne
schauen die ganz grosse linie sehen
zumal wenn eine regierung neu startet
jetzt diskutieren wir viel auch aktuell
wieder über schnell wirkende maßnahmen
das ist sicher wichtig aber
währenddessen machen ja immer mehr
wissenschaftler klar dass diese an dem
wir uns noch wesentlich länger verfolgen
wird nach omikron droht pi dann rosig so
weiter möglicherweise die menschheit
müsste sich sagen diese forscher wohl
vorbereiten auf eine für lange zeit
veränderte zukunft wie stellen sie sich
und deutschlands finanzen darauf ein
durch solidität
wir sehen das ja auch die risiken der
geldentwertung
wachsen die amerikanische notenbank hat
bereits entsprechende schritte
angekündigt die werden nicht ohne
auswirkungen auf die welt sein und
deshalb ist es richtig dass unser land
weiter an der schuldenbremse festhalten
gab ja sogar aus den reihen der cdu
stimmen hier unsere verfassung zu
verändern die schuldenbremse muss
bestand haben
ich muss schon frage beantworten dürfen
ja aber ich muss da konkreter werden
denn sie sagen schuldenbremse solidität
auf der anderen seite sagt der
einzelhandel jetzt schon in diesem hat
wenz geschäft es gibt milliardenschäden
wie seriös können denn finanzpläne
angesichts dieser situation überhaupt
sein naja sie fragen nach der sehr
langwierigen prognose bei den
öffentlichen finanzen
um ihre frage jetzt zu konkretisieren
wieder konkret auf diesen winter also
stellen sie eine andere frage als die
erste auch die will ich gerne
beantworten wir werden jetzt in der
nächsten woche wesentliche
hilfsinstrument des staates für
wirtschaft und gesellschaft verlängern
beispielsweise den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds weil die pandemie
eben nicht überwunden ist nicht in
gesundheitlicher hinsicht aber eben auch
nicht hinsichtlich der wirtschaftlichen
schäden sicher ist wir sind voll
handlungsfähig auch als neue
ampelkoalition und werden dafür sorgen
die wirtschaftlichen schäden in unserem
land zu begrenzen auch wenn das noch
jahre dauern könnte
ich möchte nicht spekulative fragen wie
sie jetzt stellen beantworten sondern
wir müssen es erreichen dass wir im
nächsten jahr zu einem agileren und
vorausschauenden krisenmanagements auch
der pandemie kommen dem zusammenhang
haben wir jetzt ja diesen krisenstab mit
dem unser gespräch begonnen hat
eingerichtet und in dem zusammenhang
werden wir auch über die erweiterung der
infrastruktur beim impfen sprechen
müssen dass die menschen so lange jetzt
auf eine auffrischungsimpfung warten
müssen und sie nicht so schnell bekommen
wie sie sich das selber wünschen dass
zum beispiel darf kein dauerzustand sein
christian lindner der fdp chef
dankeschön ich danke ihnen
das gespräch haben wir am frühen abend
aufgezeichnet und leicht gekürzt
komplett zu sehen wie immer bei zdf
heute im netz was die aktuelle corona
lage mit den intensivstationen unserer
krankenhäuser macht dürfte sollte
mittlerweile allen klar sein welche
folgen all das hat für die die nicht im
krankenhaus sind aber dort dringend hin
müssten das zeigen wir ihn jetzt in mehr
als drei viertel der deutschen
krankenhäuser wird bereits auf planbare
operationen verzichtet
das sind die nackten zahlen über die
schicksale dahinter berichtet sibylle
bassler
guido steininger quälen schmerzen große
schmerzen und das seit wochen der 54
jährige leidet an einer zyste die auf
seine organe drückt er kann sich kaum
bewegen schlecht atmen auch das sprechen
strengt an
schmerzmittel von der alternative gibt
es momentan nicht der einst kraftvolle
familienvater aus dem niederbayerischen
hengersberg fühlt sich wie ein wrack ist
verzweifelt denn das einzige was ihm
helfen würde ist eine operation doch die
ist verschoben worden weil sein zustand
nicht lebensbedrohlich ist in der klinik
sagte man ihm und seiner frau
das nicht als notfall eingestuft wird es
muss noch schlimmer werden übers netz
geworden ist war schon stunden dabei
wobei man wirklich big softie holsten
bei ausübung von django du kannst doch
immer die durch steininger ist kein
einzelfall aktuell dürfen nur notfälle
in seiner zuständigen klinik behandelt
werden planbare sogenannte elektiven
eingriffe sind seit wochen in gebieten
mit hohem inzidenz in bayern untersagt
die überlasteten cupid intensivstationen
sollen so durch eine umschichtung des
personals entlastet werden professor
matthias behrend ist sein behandelnder
arzt er würde steininger gerne operieren
darf aber nicht unsere warteliste
umfasst derzeit 60 70 patienten viel
mehr sorgen machen mehr aber als chirurg
die patientin die gar nicht erst zum
arzt gehen oder eine potenzielle auch
krankheiten einfach nicht erkannt werden
die in der tat sich verschlechtern nicht
durchgeführte operationen wartezeiten
die lebensgefährlich werden können dazu
noch der ständige druck platz zu
schaffen für neue cupid
intensivpatienten für den ärztlichen
direktor professor stefan raab ein
permanenter ausnahmezustand
wenn man liegt früher intensivpatienten
raus damit man bitte am platz bekommt wo
man dann vielleicht denkt na ja es wäre
vielleicht besser den noch ein tag oder
zwei tage länger dort zu behalten doch
bei allen anstrengungen in den letzten
tagen mussten sie wiederholt notfälle
wie herzinfarkte schlaganfälle oder
schädel-hirn-traumata an andere kliniken
verweisen man muss aber natürlich wissen
je länger der transport und diese länger
der zeitraum bis zur behandlung gibt es
der schlechteste prognose also ist das
letztendlich gewisser weise auch schon
eine erste form der triage hält dieser
zustand weiter an befürchtet der
mediziner einen kollaps des
gesundheitssystems und guido steininger
ihr ganzes leben habe sich verändert
sagt gerlinde die sorge um ihren mann
der immer so stark weist groß
zum schluss ausgeht sowie zum und
solange es nicht weiß aber natürlich
angst um
frühestens im februar sagen seine ärzte
wird er operiert werden können wenn die
korona lage es zulässt
auch das ist deutschland in diesem
winter auf die aktuelle situation guckt
jetzt kein server anhand von
besorgniserregenden zahlen in unserem
ersten nachrichtenüberblick econ
variante breitet sich auch in europa
weiter aus so hat sich in dänemark die
zahl der bestätigten fälle innerhalb von
48 stunden verdreifacht auf über 180 in
deutschland gibt es bislang vier
bestätigte fälle und das sind die
aktuellen gesamtzahlen binnen 24 stunden
wurden dem robert-koch-institut
42.000 55 neuinfektionen gemeldet das
sind
2346 weniger als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen binnen eines tages 94
todesfälle dazu die sieben tage
incidents liegt jetzt bei 4
139,2
immer mehr pflegeheimbewohner sind
offenbar auf sozialhilfe angewiesen das
berichtet das redaktions netzwerk
deutschland und bezieht sich dabei auf
daten des statistischen bundesamtes die
die linkspartei angefragt hatte demnach
lag die zahl der bedürftigen
2020 bei fast
337.000 das sind 5,4 prozent mehr als im
vorjahr als hauptgrund gelten die stark
gestiegenen eigenanteile in pflegeheimen
sie lagen im bundesdurchschnitt bei
2125 euro im monat
in indonesien sind bei einem
vulkanausbruch mindestens 13 menschen
getötet worden außerdem gibt es dutzende
verletzte viele von ihnen mit schweren
brandwunden
riesige rauchwolken legten sich über
benachbarte dörfer in panik flohen mehr
als 1000 einwohner weil der ausbruch von
einem unwetter begleitet wurde verbanden
sich regenwasser und asche zu einer
dicken schlammschicht die zähe masse
erschwert nun die rettungsarbeiten
bei protesten gegen das militärregime in
myanmar soll es mindestens fünf tote
gegeben haben das berichten mehrere
medien
laut augenzeugen raste in london ein
militärfahrzeug in die menschenmenge
anschließend eröffneten soldaten das
feuer auf die demonstranten
seit dem militärputsch im februar gibt
es immer wieder proteste gegen die
machthaber diese gehen brutal gegen ihre
kritiker vor nach angaben von
menschenrechtlern wurden schon mehr als
1300 menschen getötet und tausende
verhaftet oder verurteilt
jahrzehntelang war er ein prägendes
gesicht der us politik nun ist der
republikaner bob dole im alter von 98
jahren gestorben
mehr als ein vierteljahrhundert saß der
weltkriegsveteran im us-senat
1976 bewarb er sich als vizepräsident
unter gerald ford die beiden verloren
die wahl gegen jimmy carter als
präsidentschaftskandidat unterlag er
1996 erneut dieses mal gegen bill
clinton us präsident biden nannte dole
einen staatsmann wie es nur wenige
gegeben habe
der papst macht politik und erholt ein
thema zurück ins gewissen der welt das
immer wieder droht in vergessenheit zu
geraten aber nach wie vor da ist und
drängt und nicht einfach so weg gehen
wird nur weil es nicht mehr tagtäglich
schlagzeilen macht
franziskus ist auf der griechischen
insel lesbos wo er einen schiffbruch der
zivilisation anprangert das sind seine
worte der papst war schon mal dort bei
den flüchtlingen
2200 von ihnen harren selbst nach
angaben der behörden immer noch aus
immer noch in einem übergangslager dort
annette hilsenbeck mit mehr ein papst
der mut macht freude zeigt nahe sein
will franziskus den menschen im
flüchtlingslager auf lesbos ich bin hier
um eure gesichter zu sehen sagt er und
lenkt mit seinem besuch zugleich das
licht der aufmerksamkeit auf sie sie
soll nicht vergessen werden
lasst uns die lähmende angst überwinden
mit die todbringende gleichgültigkeit
das zynische desinteresse das in
samthandschuhen die zum tode verurteilt
die am rande stehen
lassen wir nicht zu dass das mittelmeer
sich in ein trostloses mehr der toten
verwandelt ich bitte euch lasst uns
diesen schiff potter zivilisation
stoppen
es ist eine päpstliche reise die vor
allem der flüchtlingspolitik gewidmet
ist erst zypern heute nun lesbos dass er
das zweite mal nach 2016 besucht das
große problem von den flüchtlingen hat
er schon von anfang seines pontifikats
als einer der größten menschlichen
katastrophen
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg bezeichnet
der papst hat schon oft gesagt wenn es
diese menschen fliehen eigentlich sehr
oft nicht um ein besseres leben zu haben
sondern einfach um zu leben im camp dass
der papst nun auf lesbos erlebt statt
des abgebrannten moria leben etwa 2200
menschen in containern oder zelten mit
boden ausreichend sanitären anlagen
geblieben ist die hoffnungslosigkeit das
zähe warten zermürbend die hoffnungen
die auf dem papst ruhen sind groß gerne
über unsere schwierige lage her mit ihm
sprechen ich brauche einen guten ort an
dem ich meine ausbildung fertig machen
kann ich sicher bin
jesus war ja auch ein pflicht nehmen
daher bin ich sicher dass er etwas für
die flüchtlinge tun wird den migranten
spendet der papst trost die politik und
die gesellschaft in europa geißelt er
dagegen mit scharfen worten
wir müssen bitternis zugeben dass
griechenland wie andere noch unter druck
steht und das ist europa noch immer
leute gibt die so tun als ob sie das
nichts angeht
und es ist traurig wenn als lösung
vorgeschlagen wird mit gemeinsamen
ressourcen mauern zu bauen
deutliche kritik und zugleich eine klare
ansage in welche richtung sich die
eigene kirche auch in zukunft bewegen
sollen wir sind ja im herbst des
pontifikats und das weiß ja sehr gut für
ihn ist es so dass ein christ
nicht einfach sich begnügen kann in die
messe zu gehen und so seine identität
war sondern er muss wie der gute
samaritaner sein er muss helfen es sind
die schwachen die armen denen papst
franziskus sein rückhalt gibt eine
mächtige stimme in der welt von der die
migranten auf lesbos sich so viel
erhoffen
da will einer bewusst an die ränder
gehen weil ihnen die kleinen orte
berühren nicht die großen arenen
reserve guckt jetzt auf den sport heute
ja konkret auf die formel 1 de bis zum
letzten rennen spannend bleibt beim
großen preis von saudi arabien konnte
max verstappen den weltmeistertitel
nicht klar machen lewis hamilton zog in
dem turbulenten rennen mit seinem
konkurrenten gleich das rennen auf dem
engen gefährlichen stadtkurs von jeddah
ist keines für schwache nerven kurz nach
dem start crash zunächst mit schumacher
dann auch masken und herres alle bleiben
unverletzt wenn unterbrechungen aber die
folge nach den restarts können sich max
verstappen und lewis hamilton im kampf
um die wm spitze keinen zentimeter
hamilton greift verstappen an der
kontert verschafft sich aber nicht
abkürzen einen vorteil verstappen soll
jetzt platz eins an hamilton zurückgeben
bremst völlig überraschend kollision
unvermeidlich
trotz kaputtem frontflügel ist schafft
es hamilton wenig später an verstappen
vorbeizukommen und so gewinnt lewis
hamilton vor max verstappen und valtteri
bottas in der wm-wertung punktgleichen
beiden das letztere nächste woche in abu
dhabi spannung
der kommende mittwoch beschert uns aller
voraussicht nach einen neuen
regierungschef
bundeskanzler olaf scholz an diese
wortkombination müssen auch wir uns hier
bei den nachrichten erst noch gewöhnen
dabei ist der neuer ein altbekannter
haben scholz war spd-generalsekretär
arbeitsminister bürgermeister
finanzminister seine partei wollte ihn
erst nicht als chef dafür später dann
als kanzlerkandidat und in seiner
heimatstadt hamburg haben sie sowieso
ihre eigenen scholz geschichten und
scholz erinnerungen ralf zimmermann von
seefahrt hat sich die angehört als
ziehväter von olaf scholz würden sie
sich nie bezeichnen als weggefährten der
ersten stunde aber schon günther frank
und axel selber zwei sozialdemokratische
urgesteine in hamburg rahlstedt hier im
damaligen arbeiter und angestellten
milieu ging olaf scholz zur schule trat
1975 der spd und den jungsozialisten bei
und einer brachte ihm sein parteibuch
sogar nach hause ich kam dann in der
wohnung anwenderfreundlichkeit gebeten
zu einer tasse kaffee und erich anfangen
konnte zu erzählen was wir an das tolles
machen und wo man überall mitarbeiten
kerne fragte olaf scholz wo kann ich
dann überall hingehen und ich will
unbedingt was tun
landesorganisation ja er war sehr sehr
engagiert er war ein intellektueller
ehrgeizig
würde ich sagen aber positiv ärgert sich
das muss man in der politik sein wenn
man was er erreichen will
2009 übernahm scholz in hamburg eine
heillos zerstrittene spd in der
opposition führte sie 2011 zur absoluten
mehrheit an selbstbewusstsein hat es ihm
schon damals nicht gefehlt wenn alle
sagen sie möchten dass sich die führung
der hamburger spd übernehme dann
bekommen alle das was sie bestellt haben
ich habe scholz nicht als ein
übermäßiges eu empfohlen aber als sehr
selbst überzeugt dass das was er
erarbeitet andacht hat auch richtig ist
und das ist wichtig für einen kanzler
dazu zu stehen zudem zu stehen was man
für richtig und bedeutsame
2015 war er dann gezwungen zu einer
rot-grünen koalition mit den grünen
erfolge zu teilen das war in hamburg
nicht gerade seine stärke und jetzt also
in berlin die dreier koalition das ist
ein sehr schmaler grat auf der einen
seite die überzeugung auch mitzubringen
den richtigen kurs auch vorzugeben und
auf der anderen seite wirklich auch
darauf zu vertrauen dass alle drei
partner in der summe ihrer einzelteile
mehr wollen als eben nur diese drei
partner zu sein sondern eine aufbruchs
regierung zu sein und das heißt man muss
auch vertrauen man muss auch abgeben und
loslassen können und ich glaube das
fällt ihm schwer neben vielen erfolgen
wie wohnungsbau und elbphilharmonie gab
es auch schlappen und misserfolge wie
das scheitern der olympia idee oder denn
dieser das böse g20-gipfel 2017 für und
krise hat scholz in seinem hamburger
jahren in vielen facetten erlebt wenn es
eine lehre zum kanzler gebe dann ist das
das leben von olaf scholz also eine juso
abgeordneter generalsekretär minister
bürgermeister wieder minister kanzler
ist ideal aber der kern bleibt halt olaf
scholz ist halt olaf scholz und das ist
ein bodenständiger mit beiden beinen
tatsächlich im leben stehen der mensch
diese bodenständigkeit schätzen viele
genossen bis heute an ihm und lassen
deshalb auch in rahlstedt nichts auf ihn
kommen er ist ein intelligenter mensch
und wenn er das alles einsetzt kann er
ein großer kanzler werden auch bei all
den problemen die wir jetzt in
deutschland und in europa und weltweit
haben rudern auf der alster übrigens das
war in hamburg sein lieblingssport in
jeder lage den kurs vorgeben das hat er
hier gelernt sicher auch hilfreich für
die neue herausforderung an der spree
ja und herausforderungen wird es mehr
als genug geben ab mittwoch dann so
lange alles nach ampel plan läuft als
kanzler
wird es ihnen so geht das ihnen
angesichts der gesamtlage der welt
zunehmend die orientierung abhanden
kommt dann hilft einerseits trost von
rilke forschen sie nicht nach den
antworten die ihnen nicht gegeben werden
können leben sie jetzt die fragen
vielleicht leben sie dann allmählich
ohne es zu merken eines fernen tages in
die antwort hinein wir versprechen aber
auch in der kommenden woche wieder
fragen zu stellen und mit aller kraft
nach antworten zu suchen hier sind die
themen dazu im heute-journal ausblick
von ulrike rödler
[Musik]
für viele gilt sie als ikone die
friedensnobelpreisträgerin und einstige
regierungschefin von myanmar sanssouci
die militär konter die sie anfang des
jahres weg putschte wird am montag das
urteil verkünden lassen wegen aufruf zum
widerstand
international war sie in die kritik
geraten weil sich die vertreibung der
muslimischen rohingya nicht verhindert
hatte
grüne und fdp haben es schon getan nun
ist die spd dran am montag wird olaf
scholz die namen seiner ministerriege
bekanntgeben mit spannung wird erwartet
wer auf jens spahn folgen wird
der volkswagen aufsichtsrat wird sich am
donnerstag mit der personalie herbert
diess befassen der konzernchef ist
angezählt weil er planungen zum
stellenabbau nicht mit dem betriebsrat
abgesprochen hatte vermutet wird dass
dies zwar nicht abgesetzt aber
abgestraft wird
am samstag geht es bei der spd mit
personalangelegenheiten weiter auf dem
bundesparteitag sollen lars klingbeil
und saskia esken zur neuen parteispitze
gewählt werden als spd-generalsekretär
ist der ehemalige juso chef kevin
kühnert nominiert
ein ausblick fehlt noch der aufs wetter
das wird morgen gemischt mit etwas
schnee oder schneeregen an der ostsee in
sachsen und am alpenrand im rest des
landes zeigt sich auch mal die sonne und
es bleibt trocken minus ein bis plus
fünf grad auch in den tagen danach gibt
es schnee und regen schauer dazwischen
aber auch etwas sonne dabei wird im
osten winterlich kalt im westen milder
mit bis zu 7 grad
ab morgen übernehmen hier marietta
slomka und gundula gause und sie sind
dann hoffentlich auch dabei wir zwei
verabschieden uns von ihnen im namen des
gesamten heute schon mal teams wünschen
wir hinein sehr angenehm geschickt
[Musik]